war is inevitable
one Must Destroy
in order to create
we are no Jedi
[Music]
I started hearing whispers
of thrawn's return as heir to the Empire
what happens when we find thrawn
power
such as you've never dreamed
[Music]
[Applause]
I've spent most of my life fighting a
war
that's why I'm trying to convince you to
help me prevent another one
you and I both know who could help you
with this
she's still just as stubborn as ever
I bet your master found you difficult at
times Anakin never got to finish my
training I walked away from him just
like I walked away from Sabine you've
never made things easy for me
master
as a Jedi sometimes you have to make the
decision no one else can but I'm
counting on you to see this through
nice haircut
s we have to do what's right regardless
of our personal feelings
if we don't stop throng everything will
be in vain
[Music]
Anakin spoke highly of you
I'm not here to discuss my past
we have a lot of work to do once a rebel
always a rebel
thank you
[Music]
foreign